we're gonna we're gonna go into this
next story and it's gonna be really bad
so i hope you will
you're all ready for this next story
because we're gonna talk about something
that
the amusement heavily criticized for
there is
the media that people talk about like
with air quotes and then there's actual
news outlets
local news tends to do a pretty okay job
there's a lot of
there's still the same issues that
affect local outlets the same as
national outlets
but the national outlets have a tendency
of being
i don't know wings of the democratic
party put it that way you know
the issue is right now we have
liberal media we have left-wing i i
don't like calling it liberal media
that's what it's called right that's
that's how people refer to it and then
you have conservative media
but the mainstream news and people like
you know brian stelter
they never say left-wing media they
always just say like
trump's ragging on news outlets they're
like fish not knowing they're wet almost
yeah but they will say right-wing
commentators right-wing personalities
they'll lump all of the worst people in
the world together under the banner of
right wing
if you go to the anti-defamation leagues
like terror tracker
they're like anyone anti-government is
right-wing that's amazing it's like we
talk about anti-fuzz anti-government
but there's no anti-government left-wing
category there was one one instance
where they claimed that
a black identity extremist who had
killed people was left-wing
and also i'm like well hold on a minute
isn't racial supremacy
like right wing but because of the race
you make it left or right
that's weird so so what ends up
happening is this how the media
functions
yeah what so listen we're going to get
uh we're going to get uh it's going to
be it's going to be brutal man
um i appreciate you appreciate you guys
we're going to talk about a really
really messed up story and we're going
to talk about what the media
what the media is doing so i'm giving
you guys fair warning you're going to
your blood will boil from this one check
it out
it's from the blaze and i've got an
update on this
neighbor reportedly rushes five-year-old
boy playing outside
puts a gun to his head and executes him
from the blaze
this story's been making the rounds
among many many people and i just say
many people because i see a lot of
people talking about it and i don't see
large mainstream news outlets yeah they
didn't talk about it
they didn't talk about a story like this
i saw this and i had
people asking me if i would cover it and
you know will i bring it up
and i gotta be honest my my thought
process initially was like this is
insane
however my point of view was like
i don't think i can just highlight this
one particular story
because people think the media is
ignoring it right and they should be
covering it right
and i also kind of thought like well i
mean you know
will they cover it i i mean are people
jumping the gun
you know let's see if this becomes a
story and sure enough it didn't
and now it's at the point where we have
the body camera footage from george
floyd
totally ignored totally ignored and i'm
and i'm like wait
hold on hold on a minute how many
stories like this do we have
so you know with with all due respect
and you know
maybe i could have done a better job
maybe i could have brought the story
sooner
you have the story of a five-year-old
boy who was playing outside and a dude
ran up
because of some beef executed a little
kid
and this doesn't make it's not just
about this story
there's a bunch of stories like this i
remember do you remember when
in uh in new york there were people
running up to
orthodox and acidic jews and just
beating them yep
and just where was it why why does it
fall on conservatives
to support the jewish community when
they were being attacked in new york
city yeah
national media look i think it's obvious
the the the narrative they're pushing
writing black lives matter in the
streets without approval
the it's it's it's intended to help the
democratic party
yeah i mean it's it's bill de blasio it
is literally democrats painting these
messages
yeah and then it without permission
right yeah and taxpayer money
the moment someone challenges it what do
we get shut it down
well not bill de blasio he was like no
he said
he said black lives matter transcends
politics oh does it
so what so does blue lives matter yeah i
thought i thought everybody liked cops
how does blue how does blue lives matter
not transcend politics
police exist literally everywhere yeah
no it's apparently a political statement
to say you support police now
but not black lives matter i want to
read you the stories i want to make sure
you all
understand this is from the blaze they
say a five-year-old boy is dead
after a man in wilson north carolina
reportedly ran up to the child while he
was playing in a neighborhood street
and fatally shot the child in the head
according to a report from wral tv
the shooting took place on sunday canon
hinnon
was playing outside his father's house
on the dusky summer evening
when their neighbor 25 year old darius n
sessoms
charged cannon produced a handgun and
shot him in the head
the child's seven-year-old and
eight-year-old siblings witnessed the
murder
first responders came to the scene and
transported the little boy to wilson
medical center
where he was pronounced dead doris
lebron
a neighbor said she witnessed sessoms
running up to cannon
putting the gun to his head and firing
the weapon before fleeing the scene into
his own home
she couldn't believe her eyes quote my
first reaction was he's playing with the
kids you were called
for a second i thought that couldn't
happen people don't run across the
street and kill kids
lebron said the situation became all too
real when she saw the child's father
react to the horrific scene
authorities took sessoms into custody on
monday night and charged him with first
degree murder
he is being held in the wilson county
jail without bond
authorities have not yet determined a
motive in the shooting but insisted that
the killing wasn't a random wasn't it
wasn't random
as sessoms was reportedly friendly with
canon's father a gofundme page was set
up to benefit the family
uh has raised at least five thousand
five hundred and seventy seven dollars
the time of this reporting i wanna stop
there too
i see antifa far leftist riders
they go around and they smash windows
they attack people and they raise
80 grand 30 grand 40 grand yep
the media doesn't cover these stories
this is not the only story these stories
happens all the time and i think
i think i've been desensitized to them
especially growing up in chicago
i wonder why it is that this isn't
national news
this doesn't make sense to me because
this you want to talk about not a
political issue
this is not a political issue it is it
shouldn't be
it shouldn't be it's murder and it
shouldn't be political in any way at all
um
and then they're i think that they're
choosing to make it political
by refusing to cover it it bothers me a
lot
like it's an issue we have an update
from the blaze hashtag
say his name trends after mainstream
media silence on the atrocious
killing of of five-year-old ken and
hinnon
why is there a media blackout on the
execution killing of a five-year-old boy
who was innocently riding his bicycle
i don't i don't agree with the term
blackout you know i think blackout
implies they're all intentionally saying
don't run the story yeah
i think it's fair if you wanna if you
believe that like if in your opinion
you're like i don't trust the median i
think they're gonna do that
you know i personally wouldn't say
blackout i would say they don't care
about you they don't care about this kid
they don't care about these stories
and i think that's worse that is way
worse i think it's way worse
i think it's one thing to imply that the
media is actively seeing this and going
oh no we better not let anyone know
that implies they know it's bad and they
and they that they actually understand
the ramifications of a murder like this
and they're worried about what people
will think it's like no i think they
ignore it
they ignore it you really think they
ignore it or you think they don't even
care that's what i mean
i think they see it and they go like i
think they go huh
because they don't even see like what
i'm trying to say is
a regular person see the stories like
this and they share it they're like
what is this why does something like
this happen
and why are there other stories like
this there's videos of people being
beaten in the street
and the media won't talk about it it's
not because i think there's a blackout
that would imply they understand that
people are are shocked by this
it's that they don't want it they don't
care
it just it just doesn't faze them at all
they're indifferent
i was always told growing up the
opposite of love is not hate it's
indifference i think it's right
and that's what this is complete and
total indifference to the fact that
we've had murders going up in this
country violent violent crime
and we're witnessing in various cities
the district attorneys are straight up
saying we will not prosecute
yeah portland yeah yeah chicago so
i i maybe this is just because i took
the moral foundations test and i'm
really really high in
caring i think you're really high i'm
really i'm really i'm good that's going
to be clipped out of context
i'm really high in caring and it baffles
me
that you could just discard this and
just decide not to cover it
like what what could possess you that's
that's kind of ghoulish to be able to
say i don't think this is important i
don't think this matters
so for those that aren't familiar
there's uh it's jonathan height
yeah moral foundations test and it's
it's a really really fascinating
assessment
it finds that basically conservatives
have a balance of
all their six moral foundations i think
so yeah yeah you want to pull it up yeah
yeah
so at conservatives you can pat
yourselves on the back whether this
matters for you or not liberals
i i don't think it's necessarily a bad
thing but it's interesting
there are six moral foundations do you
have them yeah hold on let me grab it
it's like uh careful oh you've got it
yeah there you go
okay do they do they actually list the
foundations on here no i think that you
have to actually
go through the whole thing ah that's boo
i don't know here what let's uh
do you want you want to just spam it
yeah let's make it crazy
and then we'll show you this to explain
what's going on oh i can just go through
all the way in the middle
we'll be super moderate we'll be super
centrists here all right we're going to
give it a totally fake answer
and see what it comes up with everything
might be even i don't know
the moral foundations are like care
fairness
loyalty authority purity purity weird to
me so
here we actually have here here are the
six care fairness purity loyalty
authority
and liberty and you can see here we uh
so lydia just spammed
moderate the whole way across look how
moderate we are yeah and but but it's
conservative it says your strongest
moral foundation is loyalty
your morality is closest to that of a
conservative conservatives tend to have
a balance of
all of the moral foundations that's
really interesting very interesting
and and what's what's really fascinating
to me about it is
it's conservative like in general
this is not a new thing for
conservatives right but
liberals tend to have care and fairness
really high
and you can look at the blue here care
is at like 78
fairness is it like you know 79 and then
loyalty authority
purity and liberty are lower and purity
is like
the lowest next to libertarian and
conservatives in red
are balanced across the board yeah
interestingly and i find this hilarious
libertarians are low on everything
except liberty and that kind of makes
they're like i don't care what you do or
who you do it to
leave me alone yeah exactly but this is
what's fascinating
authority is important to recognize but
not to just
blindly follow we understand why why
authority is important to make sure a
system can function people can survive
right purity is relatively important as
well and it has to do
with avoiding disease and things like
this yeah like having borders and
boundaries
right liberals or i should say left
liberal what i'm gonna call it have like
none they don't think that's important
none they do have mo
they do have a decent amount of liberty
that's interesting too but lower than
conservatives
liberals obviously believe less in
liberty than conservatives
less in authority less in loyalty more
care and more fairness
yeah i i challenge this i don't believe
it really i don't believe that care
really is i think fairness
but i don't think they care really yeah
because when i talk to
my like when i drive in a conversation
with maybe it's whatever default liberal
is
when i have conversations with them and
i say something like
do you do you ever actually ask a
conservative how they feel
of course they don't so do you think
it's just like an in-group thing
like where they really really want to
protect their group yes
yeah so it's very tribal that's why
maybe fairness isn't true either
i don't think fairness is fair either i
got to be completely honest because you
can take a look at this
when you have antifa black lives matter
rioters smashing and destroying small
businesses
causing suffering among those who are
the most vulnerable among us
immigrant families where are those who
care who have care
and fairness coming out and saying this
was wrong
hmm you might be right yeah i don't know
what it is these people are
maybe maybe you you'd find that the the
antifa people
they score low in everything but
authority because because i'm curious
about this right
yeah they give you a they give you a
graph of left liberal conservative and
libertarian what about authoritarian
yeah what about like far far far left
yeah yeah well not even just but not
just far left but authoritarian in
general
that's true that's not really uh would
they have low liberty and really high
authority
yeah and probably really high purity so
anyway the reason
uh we got into this in the context of um
uh ken and hinnant is specifically about
they don't care right
and i'm like how can they claim to be
liberal if they literally don't care
about these things
yeah certainly this story should make
the average person cry
yeah like i mean this this was like
getting punched in the chest
seriously and but you know i've seen so
many stories
like this and and i mean even when i saw
the george floyd videos
like i was moved i was like i'm like man
even when you watch the body camera
footage
and you realize look he was resisting he
uh so for those that aren't familiar
they they publish the body camera
footage
yeah now we know he kicked his way out
of the suv
he was saying uh he was resisting and he
was saying
hold me on the ground hold me on the
ground several times
i'm still upset when i see that video of
him saying i can't breathe
mama and stuff like that it it it pains
me man i'm i'm absolutely opposed to
that
to the death penalty recognizing there's
no absolutes right i understand
there are certain circumstances that
even i have no control over
right conflict exists murderers exist
and sometimes
i think in the confines of the state if
you've subdued someone and they're
unable to actually hurt anybody anymore
that's when i'm like i don't think it's
right to kill
but i understand if i saw this dude walk
up to that kid and pull out a gun
that guy'd probably die yep if i if i if
i had the means
you know what i mean i think most people
would agree it doesn't matter who the
person is
you watch them walk up to a kid and draw
a gun if you had the power
if you would snap your fingers and they
would die in agonizing death and prevent
that death you would do it in defense of
others yeah absolutely and it's
and and it's unfortunate but this kid
didn't deserve what he got
no man this this family the siblings
this this poor kid man
right in front of his siblings too and
it the george floyd thing is awful
it's sad that's traumatizing and i wish
that had never happened
but at the same time george floyd got a
heck of a lot more of a chance at life
than this little five-year-old kid
and i wish that he were getting as much
attention and as much of a memory like a
memorial
as george floyd did check check check
out these tweets jason howard and says
canon hints say his name
cnn nbc cbs abc zero results
zero results zero results not even a
mention
it's crazy i mean if cnn ran one article
where they're like hey this thing
happened
and that was it and there was no big
like you know brian selter didn't come
on the air and talk about it i'd be like
they did the story you know what i mean
they talk about it whether or not people
in politics care is entirely up to them
it's it's crazy to me i think you know i
was reading this
medium post from a woman named carrie
smith about how she's a liberal and
she's going to vote for trump
and it's because the left isn't liberal
anymore it's because they're lying she
wrote about how
in the 2016 cycle she was watching
videos of trump supporters being beaten
and it made her cry yeah dude but she
still believed it was like
trump was awful and all these things
were really bad and these supporters
were really bad
and it wasn't until she actually talked
to people that she learned these are
regular people
thinking feeling human beings you know
what i mean but even she had empathy
when she saw these videos of trump
supporters being attacked yeah
absolutely
what are these people on on twitter that
are just
pure wads of hate it's like all the hate
it's like
it reminds me of uh uh you ever see
ghostbusters too
no i'm sorry okay so in ghostbusters 2
there's pink slime
and when they're negative it bubbles and
expands and it's like you know it's
feeding off negative energy
okay okay that's what twitter is it's
like um what was the name of the bad guy
from ghostbusters too i can't remember
his name uh shoot i don't know let me
see
you didn't see it no it was uh it was a
guy in the painting you know whatever
but uh if if man if if if they remade
ghostbusters two storyline today with
twitter
it's just it's putrid yeah
and and i don't even wanna know people
are saying about this kid so we got a
tweet here from uh kyle cashev he says
yesterday a five-year-old was riding his
bike playing outside
with uh outside his house with his two
sisters his neighbor with already
multiple felony charges walked up to him
and shot him dead at point blank
five years old jfc where the h
is the media coverage say his name
cassandra fairbank says
just so everyone understands a lone
woman calling the police on a stranger
threatening her dog
in a park is considered national news
the murder of cannon hinnon
is not she's got a point she dab she she
does a huge point
how many stupid karen videos do they
prop up our news media does not serve
us thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you